la scène est extraordinaire des patients
dépressifs espira thouars prêté à bord
de leur propre voiture
un service au volant forcer les urgences
de l'hôpital cotugno de naples n'ont
plus de place à l'intérieur il a cet
homme fait les cent pas depuis près de
deux heures pendant que son frère
endormi dans la voiture reçoit de
l'oxygène il vient vers notre caméra
forcé à l'écart visiblement troublés par
la situation sur un peu plus de temps en
temps du personnel médical vient relever
le niveau d'oxygène des patients et
repart lui restera comme ça pendant plus
de six heures auprès de son frère malade
at il peur
si l'image qu'offre l'hôpital de cotugno
et dégoûtantes
c'est cette vidéo qui a choqué le pays
tout entier la semaine dernière dans les
toilettes de l'urgence du plus grand
hôpital de naples un patient à filmer
cet homme de 84 ans jean chez au sol
mort charmant rosario lamonica est
l'auteur de la vidéo
il était aux urgences de l'hôpital
cardarelli lui même atteint de l'aco
vide vers 2 heures du matin une personne
âgée sortie de son lit l'homme avait
besoin d'elle pour aller aux toilettes
je lui dit de s'asseoir sur le dip
après une demi-heure il n'en pouvait
plus d'attendre il s'est rendu dans la
salle de bains est entré et fait ce
qu'il avait à faire
après cinq minutes j'ai ouvert la porte
ils étaient toujours assis dans la salle
de bain après 7 minutes
j'ai vérifié à nouveau et il était par
terre et tendu avec sa tête près de la
porte et ses pieds vers lévis personne
pour m'aider
les médecins n'étaient pas là juste les
gardiens de sécurité qui disait
attendait les médecins comme il ne met
des poses j'ai pris le téléphone et j'ai
fait la vidéo pour ma femme à
l'extérieur
la publication des images qu'il a filmée
a déclenché une enquête du procureur
national qui doit déterminer si
l'hôpital fait preuve de négligence
d'administration du centre hospitalier
n'a pas voulu commenter avant la
conclusion de l'enquète tout nous
demande d'accès aux hôpitaux de naples
ont été refusés par l'autorité régionale
de la santé
le personnel médical a aussi été avisés
par écrit qu'il n'était en aucun cas
autorisés à parler de la pandémie et de
la situation dans les hôpitaux
l'un des principaux syndicats de
médecins nous a remis des images filmées
par certains de leurs membres dont les
services co vide
on y voit des salles de soins débordés
de patients des corridors où le matériel
et les déchets s'accumulent parfois même
tout près de ses patients chez loncin
solim potenza sa tristesse
cela nous donne un sentiment
d'impuissance un grand sentiment
d'impuissance et de tristesse car cela
vous fait comprendre que malheureusement
le rêve que vous aviez d'aider les gens
se heurtent souvent au mur de la
politique
le maire de naples accuse le gouverneur
de la région de vouloir cacher la
gravité de la crise sanitaire et des
failles du système hospitalier
si vous regardez les bulletins officiels
chaque jour il semble y avoir un grand
nombre de lits d'hôpitaux des soins
intensifs et que seulement un tiers des
lits sont occupés
mais ce n'est pas le cas donc cela
signifie qu'il joue aussi sur les
données ils mettent des chiffres qui ne
correspondent pas à la réalité
autrement dit ils parlent de numéros
pour lee qui peut être activée qui n'est
pas un lit réel ou parce qu'il n'ya
peut-être pas encore de ventilateurs
connectés ou parce qu'il n'y a pas
d'annoncé east d'infirmières ou de
réanimateurs on peut aussi avoir un lit
mais si on n'a pas de médecin
on en a pas vraiment
[Musique]
beaucoup de gens vraiment peur
maintenant ces dix personnes meurent ils
ne le disent même pas aux membres des
familles ils ne savent pas quoi faire
ils n'osent pas aller contre la volonté
de l'état contre les médecins contre les
gouverneurs ils ne veulent pas d'ennuis
je dis qu'il faut se rebeller gentiment
faire une révolte dire
td nous nous pouvons être sauvé une
majorité d'italiens le croient les
mesures sanitaires adopté ne suffisent
pas la campagne a été déclarée zone
rouge ce dimanche comme les trois-quarts
de l'italie le travail se poursuit mais
les commerces d'un essentielles sont
fermées malgré les pressions des
médecins et du ministre de la santé le
président de cpnt résiste toujours à
l'idée d'un confinement national
généralisé